in the last video we saw how you can
actually view a demand curve is actually
a marginal benefit curve marginal
benefit curve that for any given
quantity of the good you're selling that
that point on the curve is actually
showing the marginal benefit for that
incremental unit so this is a marginal
benefit for that first unit this is the
marginal benefit for that second unit
and there's multiple ways that you could
view this assuming that we're talking
about this new car here maybe if you're
going to only sell one unit someone
really wants it really bad the benefit
for them the marginal benefit for that
first unit for them is going to be
$60,000 now let's say if you want to
sell two units that second unit might be
bought by that same person and they
might say well I already have one car
the benefit of getting that second one
is only fifty thousand that's the point
at which I am neutral that's the point
at which I I'm right on the fence of
what willing to buy that car or it might
be another person another person who's
just not as enamoured as the first
person is okay for fifteen thousand I do
like that car and then for the third the
third person there it once again they're
not as enamoured as the first two they
would be willing to buy it for forty
thousand dollars and what we saw is at
some point you could say look let's say
we decide that the price ends up being
for whatever reason the price ends up
being $30,000 $30,000 and so when the
price is $30,000 we saw this is kind of
viewing it in the traditional notion of
at a price what quantity were selling it
but when you think about that reality
what's actually happening is that this
fourth person is right on the fence
they're marginal benefit is exactly
$30,000 so in their mind they're saying
I am I am giving away $30,000 in
exchange for that I'm getting something
that is worth $30,000 so it's kind of
like hey well you will be willing to
trade this dollar for $1 well you
probably be kind of on the fence about
that you could you're very close to
going either way you feel like it's a
good deal if you could get for maybe a
penny less it's a bad deal or if you
were if you were getting it for a penny
more so right on the fence but you're
going to just barely get this fourth
person to transact at this price but
what we hinted at is if you do have one
price for everybody in the future we'll
talk about not having one price for
everybody but if you did have one price
for everyone
these first these first units were kind
of sold below where they could have been
sold they were sold below their margin
will benefit so remember we're viewing
this the same demand curve we're not
viewing as a marginal benefit curve so
this first unit this first unit right
over here it could have been sold at
sixty thousand dollars but now we're
selling it for thirty thousand dollars
so this right over here this was thirty
thousand dollars I'll just write thirty
for thirty thousand dollars the marginal
benefit is thirty thousand dollars
higher than the actual price the
marginal benefit of that unit the
benefit that the market got out of it is
thirty thousand dollars higher than the
price the marginal benefit for the
second unit is twenty thousand dollars
higher than the price at which the
product is being sold the marginal
benefit for this third unit for this
third unit assuming this is forty is
$10,000 $10,000 or another way to think
about it is the consumer surplus for
this first unit was thirty thousand
dollars the consumers got thirty
thousand dollars more in benefit
marginal benefit for them in value for
themselves than they had to pay for it
here the consumer surplus was twenty
thousand dollars the consumer got twenty
thousand more in value than that second
consumer was willing to pay for it and
here is ten thousand dollars and then
this fourth consumer is neutral the
marginal benefit is what they paid for
it and so when you think about this you
say well what's the total what's the
total consumer surplus here let me write
this down what is the total consumer
consumer surplus and another way of
thinking about it is what is the total
excess of marginal benefit above and
beyond the price paid so how much
surplus marginal benefit did they get if
you take out the price paid and over
here the total consumer surplus is going
to be the thirty thousand dollars for
that first unit plus the twenty thousand
dollars for that second unit plus the
ten thousand dollars plus the ten
thousand dollars for that third unit and
so the total consumer surplus in this
scenario when we sold four units at
thirty thousand dollars is and we're
assuming we're selling cars here so we
can't sell parts of cars here we can't
sell 1.1 cars I guess if we're talking
about averages maybe we could but let's
just say we're selling just whole
numbers of cars here the total consumer
surplus in this situation with
30 plus 20 plus 10 which is $60,000 or
everything's in thousand so this is
$60,000 so in this scenario in that week
the consumers would get $60,000 more in
benefit for them and perceived benefit
for them than what they actually had to
pay for it and if you think about it
it's a little uh Nydia for the seller
because you know they were selling that
something at a lower price and maybe
what they could have gotten from these
at least these first few consumers here
and that was because they just really
based on the model that we have here
they just had to set one price